uh why don't we try oh I don't know
maybe Emily from Colorado Emily from
Colorado welcome to the program
Emily from Colorado I've invited you in
hello David can you hear me I can hear
you fine Emily thank you great I hope
your day is going well it's going well
thanks
um so why let's talk about lying sure uh
politicians have always done this uh
forever but with trump it became this
sort of comical like spectator sport
right and he told her some kind of robot
who can't be destroyed and only gains
power through lies he was President
um but now we have Congressman George
Santos boxing World European and tallest
man alive yeah among other accolades
um and he's lying a lot and really badly
right and it's about his credentials and
his identity and it's getting a lot of
attention and people are calling for his
resignation but no one's making him
resign no and so my question is like how
is there no way to make him resign that
says if you lie to the American people
that you're fired well that would be a
very hard that that law that would be a
very hard law not only to pass but also
to enforce but you're pointing out
something interesting which is
politicians have lied for a long time
but there was a different type of lie
that was normalized by Trump and so
before Trump politicians would lie but
most of the lies were things like you
know I lowered the deficit no you raised
the deficit and it's like well it either
went down or it went up but you could
sort of massage data and figure out some
narrow definition to make what you're
saying marginally plausible where it's
not an out and out lie that type of line
you're saying there was more new ones
there was more Nuance to the lies and
they were a different type it wasn't
like oh I I have a different name and I
had jobs I did right Trump normalized
a different type of lie and the types of
lies that George Anthony devolder Santos
has been telling are the types of lies
that were normalized by trumpism
as far as the resignation part I mean
listen Republicans don't seem to want to
force a vote on his resignation and they
have the majority so it's a very tough
situation
right I feel like I I don't
protect democracy from corruption with
this two-party system right and you know
it's a small margin in the house and to
some degree Republicans might be
thinking well if we force devolder out
or George or Anthony whatever you want
to call them all of them if we force
them out
um and then we lose one of the small
margin that we have and then maybe
someone dies or resigns or whatever and
then all of a sudden we may end up
losing control altogether and I think
that that's their primary motivation
yeah yeah it's depressing
it's a huge problem I don't know and I
don't know how we're going to dismantle
the two-party system in America anytime
soon well you've got to do campaign
Finance reform you have to change how
our elections are you know there's so
many things that have to be done
proportional representation would be a
good step forward none none of which are
happening in the next year and a half I
can tell you that Emily no well uh yeah
it's frustrating and I'm glad you're
frustrated with me I'm with you all the
rest of it I'm with you I'm with you
thank you Emily appreciate the call see
you later all right there is Emily from
Colorado capping off
I would call it an eight out of ten
today as far as calls are concerned only
three bleeps needed and only two dropped
calls which is really not bad really not
bad all right we'll take a quick break
we'll see everybody very soon and much
more coming up on the Friday show right
after this